let me jump to this story right here
from NewsBusters CNN Tapper finally
discover misleading covet
hospitalization numbers my response to
this is conspiracy theorists 49 837
corporate press zero this is this is
something that you know Independent
Media has talked about for some time
it's something that the quote-unquote
conspiracy theorists have been saying
for some time that there is a difference
between being hospitalized with covid
meaning you went there for some reason
it turns out you had coveted and being
hospitalized from coven NewsBusters
reports for nearly two years and with
the midterm election coming up
conservatives and Republicans were
vilified as conspiracy theorists for
raising questions about covet
hospitalization numbers when it came to
who was there because of covid and who
just happened to be infected on Monday
CNN and anchor uh CNN and anchor Jake
Jake Tapper finally arrived at the scene
to ask the obvious questions after CDC
director Dr Rachelle wolenski admitted
to Fox News the numbers inflated by
upwards of 40 percent Tapper prefaced
his late Revelation by prefacing to
CNN's doctors Sanjay Gupta that quote
the case numbers aren't really a
significant as significant as
hospitalizations because what's
important is how sick people are getting
and since CNN had obfuscated the idea
that the CDC was misleading people
Tapper had to spell out what was going
on over the weekend the CDC director Dr
Rachelle wolenski was asked how many
people are in the hospital for coven
versus how many people are in the
hospital with covid meaning they're for
uh that they're there for some reason
and it's also true they have coveted
after playing the sound bite of wolinski
admitting up to 40 percent of the
patients who are coming in with covid
are coming in not because they're sick
with covet but because they're sick with
something else Tapper seemed a bit
surprised and called it misleading
saying so the hospitals are still
stretched thin because of this so I'm
not trying to take away from that but if
40 percent in some hospitals 40 of the
people who have covet don't necessarily
have problematic covet they're there
because they got in a car accident
they're there because you know they
bumped their head and they're being
included as as in the hospital with
coven that number seems kind of
misleading and there you go I mean it's
something we've long talked about and
now finally it's hitting the mainstream
and I I why is it why do you guys think
it is
not hurting people that bad relative to
the old versions that's not what I mean
what I mean is this data has been out
there already I think the rapper got
Omicron I don't know if he did and he
was like what this was so you this was
like nothing why why are people wigging
out and so now he's like and there's the
with and from thing and so it's all like
clicking for him now that's my personal
there's a lot of things at play here and
I remember early on when everything was
happening there was a case of a man
being shot in the head that was listed
as an official covet death I believe in
California and I'm like how how does
that make sense this goes along I
believe to what we were saying before if
you inflate the numbers if you make them
higher you're going to scare a lot more
people if you make them believe that you
might be a huge victim here you might be
hurt the chances of being hurt are high
high and as soon as I heard this story
I'm like yes of course we've been
talking about this for months because
hospitals also are being paid for every
coveted patient that they have are also
being paid for putting patients on
ventilators and are also being paid for
coveted patients dying so you know I
don't I don't think there's you know in
some instances a financial incentive but
but there is a lot of money Changing
Hands here when the numbers go a
specific way here that do allude that
there is a possibility that this is true
we got the story from USA Today our
ruling true we rate the claim that
hospitals get paid more if patients are
listed as covid-19 and on ventilators as
true hospitals and doctors do get paid
more for Medicare patients diagnosed
with covid-19 or if it's considered
presumed they have covid-19 absent a
laboratory confirmed test and three
times more if the patients are placed on
a ventilator to cover the cost of care
and loss of business resulting from a
shift in focus to treat covid-19 cases
this is what people were saying all
throughout the last year if you get if
you go to the hospital this is this is
from April 27 2020. it's almost two year
years ago USA Today told us this and
CNN's only now bringing it up yeah
um in the long history of uh bromide's
platitudes and tropes most have been
ultimately debunked over time they
become conventional wisdom and they
collapse under the weight of their own
nonsense never has followed the money
been debunked never ever once has it not
proven to lead you to the place where
the truth is you it might not be totally
dispositive but you can't you can't
minimize the importance of people acting
in their own Financial best interests I
don't care who they are I don't care if
they're elected I don't care if they're
scientists it just doesn't happen that's
an extraordinary thing to think about
the hundreds of thousands the millions
of dollars that are in the wind based on
a decision that ultimately is going to
be reported as fact that's a heck of a
thing yep cubono is always the question
that a lot of people have profits who
benefits who gets something from this
and for the government to incentivize
and take our money because people think
it's free money people think that a lot
of these procedures a lot of these
products are free they're not we're
paying for them in one way or another
but but for the government to
incentivize and pay hospitals to to to
to get give them more money when they
have more coveted cases more ventilators
more debt is again incentivizing
something that is obviously something
that clearly shouldn't be incentivized
and and for that to happen it's
absolutely crazy we've been saying it
for years and now we finally know about
it is this the breaking point you know
are we are you mentioned I think you
just mentioned a moment ago people are
starting to get less scared of this well
I for me there's always uh I call it a
POS or a period of splat all things have
to go Splat right before you punch
through and and there's it's not written
in the stars I don't I don't know when
it is exactly but this will tip right
and it'll be a combination of things
and for me I I can feel it I I feel
that a lot of things that a lot of
people I hold in high regard have been
saying for 18 months are getting a kind
of snowball feel behind it and and so
yeah I think I don't know that it'll get
worse before it gets better it might get
a little weirder over the next couple of
weeks but look if if I were to guess I'd
say we're much much much closer to the
end well this goes along with the theory
that I was actually talking about a few
weeks ago that goes along with a lot of
what medical professionals are saying is
that because this omnicron is so
transmissive and less lethal that it
will run through people run through
countries and then people will go out
the other end with natural immunity and
therefore absolutely get rid of this uh
pandemic so this is a train of thinking
that's that's out there right now and I
think a lot of people in power might be
realizing that and that's why we're
having these shock announcements by the
CDC by CNN going back on essentially a
lot of the falsehoods surrounding this
entire story because the game could be
over in just a few weeks from now and
that means means a lot of ramifications
for a lot of the people that betrayed us
it needs to be over especially
politically absolutely it's going to be
a disaster for those who are advocating
for covet policies come November well
this is what I said after coming from
New York cities is talking to people
there they had enough they're they're
sick of complying with the whims of this
Insanity they're they're sick of just
just going along being told to obey to
to get permission to go to the store to
go to the theaters it's absolutely
insane and for for Democrats to win
politically they have to get rid of this
idea that they have to be the nanny
state of the individual controlling
every aspect of their existence and
that's why with the upcoming elections
that was another reason I brought up I
think it was in the sponsor Lounge that
me and you were talking about this my
kind of overall Theory why why this is
going to be ending very soon because
this is extremely unpopular this goes
against the free spirit the free human
will and there's no way they could get
away with this moving forward from my
perspective from what I see and there's
also this feeling as Mike explained that
that it's there and and look I think
there's something even bigger under all
of it we can talk about the politics and
we can talk about the science but you
remember Hans Christian Anderson wrote
an amazing story called The Emperor's
New Clothes oh yeah okay now if if you
don't know the story the bottom line is
the Emperor was convinced that his new
clothes were beautiful and the tailors
didn't really make any clothes at all he
was naked and he sat naked on his throne
as he was paraded down the street and
all of the townspeople came out and they
all oohed and odd at how beautiful his
clothes were and so it was just this
giant weird happy fiction unfolding in
this little town until a kid
a kid pointed at the emperor and said
he's naked and and then you're right it
was Hush comes over the crowd and then
somebody else said well you know he does
appear to be conspicuously nude right
and and so if you look back at the last
18 months guys and and ask yourself okay
who's the kid who's the kid in the crowd
we can all probably think you know Joe
Rogan
we were all thinking it we are Joseph in
the crowd
um uh Ben Shapiro's a kid in the crowd
um you right I mean in a very very small
way I was saying some things very very
early on that got a lot of pushback with
regard to wait a second I'm not I'm not
trying to be disrespectful and I'm and
I'm not a Luddite but I have some
questions especially when Gavin is
dining out Nancy's getting her hair done
and I I have some questions right so I
think in a lot of ways to your point the
the temptation to say I told you so is
something that we ought to resist but
it's also something we ought to
acknowledge because
if you've spent the last 18 months being
that kid in the crowd and now you're
finally starting to feel like oh wait a
minute okay so I'm not the only one that
sees 40 percent of the people in the
hospital are not there because of but
with that that that's language matters
even little prepositions right that's a
big big big deal yeah if you listen to
them talk Tapper at one point says that
they're they're with asymptomatic a
bunch of these 40 they just detected it
and well maybe it's because they're
getting money I like the uh you know
what you're saying about the kid in the
crowd that's the story but I also wonder
if there's another Trope there and
that's you know the king is demanding of
the subjects do as I say or else and
then the jester mocks him and everyone
laughs and he says don't laugh at me and
then Jester mocks him again and that
depowers the despot that's right so
that's that's you know possible that's
kind of how I see you know Joe Rogan
he's a comedian and when he does his
show and he does his comedy when he does
entertainment be it serious or otherwise
people like being a part of it it feels
good so it's not necessarily the same
thing as the kids saying you know you
have no clothes and everyone kind of
being like well he said it I guess he's
right but also people feeling like now
it's now it's okay because everyone's
laughing together the point is it had to
be the kid because the adults couldn't
do it now in this Corollary
look it could have been Jake Tapper 18
months ago but it wasn't it could have
been Anderson Cooper it could have go
down the list and look at all of the
journalists who could have been that kid
who could have been Rogan what what did
it take to really start the Splat series
of dominoes to go it took a comedian who
got famous for eating maggots on a
reality show I don't think he encouraged
other people in the background no no he
would eat one to shame them oh yeah no
Joe would eat a maggot are you kidding
and and a kickboxer and a martial artist
yeah that that's what we needed to get
Robert Malone out there to get the whole
getter thing happening yeah it's crazy
right people never know how it's going
to start and we never know how it's
going to Splat but it's almost always
the result of an unlikely voice but it's
it's it's it's amazing how it I'm just
flabbergasted at the thought that Joe
Rogan is Our Generations Like Walter
Steve Bannon explained it to us if you
remember what he was telling us when he
was here as a guest that during the
during the you know major uh historical
events like the Civil War or the
Revolutionary War it's never the
politicians of the people in prominence
that are the significant historical
figures it's always the the laborers the
farmers the the people who are affected
by these changes and decide to stand up
and and represent bigger ideas
themselves because of how affected they
are by them thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel Monday through Friday at 8
pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this Channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time